chez wah wah chihuahua chihuahua des
cartes serait moqué de cette scène en
disant qu'il s'agit simplement d'un
rambo sur un robot ben ali pour lui
aristote est une machine ne t'inquiète
pas celle des bêtises enfin bon on peut
quand même se demander est ce qu'un
chihuahua est vraiment comparable à une
machine je suis romain je suis avec
aristote le cobaye de cette vidéo et
vous êtes sûr mais l'idée de culture
générale
[Musique]
une des théories les plus connus de
descartes et celle de l'animal machine
qu'il expose notamment dans sa lettre au
marquis de newcastle pas besoin d'un
dessin
l'idée c'est que aristote ne serait en
réalité rien d'autre qu'une machine
élaboré c'est la physique mécaniste du
xviie siècle qui a inspiré cette théorie
aux philosophes
en gros le monde est rempli de
substances de corps qui ont des
caractéristiques géométriques et qui
peuvent s'entrechoquer et ainsi se
transmettre le mouvement de proche en
proche
c'est donc ça la vision du monde qui
réduit aristote un rouge allez on va un
peu plus dans le détail
alors je précise que pour faire cette
vidéo j'ai sollicité l'avis du
vétérinaire d'aristote le docteur
feraoun qui exerce à paris
un vétérinaire exceptionnelle dans la
mesure où est aussi un érudit qui aiment
la philosophie je me souviens d'ailleurs
que la première fois que je suis venu on
a parlé des théories d'aristote le
philosophe 1 par le chien
regardez donc la vidéo jusqu'à la
conclusion parce que je vous y dire est
ce que pense le docteur feraoun de la
théorie de l'animal machine et vous
verrez que son avis est très intéressant
parce que c'est la vie de quelqu'un qui
est à la fois un expert scientifique des
animaux un praticien qui les connaît de
très près qui a beaucoup d'expérience
mais c'est aussi l'avis de quelqu'un qui
interroge sa pratique
avec du recul qui réfléchit beaucoup au
rapport de l'homme à l'animal et qui est
très au fait des débats passé et
contemporains
bref j'ai trouvé les explications du
docteur feraoun passionnante
c'est probablement je pense la vie le
plus éclairé possible sur la question à
l'heure actuelle
vous allez voir que la théorie de
l'animal machine est importante parce
qu'elle a des implications pour l'homme
et oui est-ce que je suis
fondamentalement si différent dans les
stocks
j'espère que la réponse est oui
[Musique]
la théorie de l'animal machine réduit un
chihuahua à sa dimension mécanique
en effet des cartes explique le
comportement animal entièrement par
l'instinct or l'instinct c'est un
ensemble de mécanismes qui s'active
automatiquement en réaction aux signes
aux produits par les circonstances
chaque stimulus extérieur entraîne une
réponses comportementales que l'homme
peut prévoir
par exemple si je présente bel os à
stoke il va systématiquement devenir fou
parce que son instinct lui fait voir
l'ours comme une ressource cruciale pour
sa survie comme descartes écrit à
l'époque des premières poupées
articulées dont les fonctionnements et
merveilles le public et il ne voit
aucune différence entre ces petites
machines produites par l'homme et les
animaux
c'est juste que les animaux sont
mécaniquement beaucoup plus élaboré mais
ils ne sont en définitive que des
combinaisons de pièces formant des
rouages sans conscience ni penser au
xviiie siècle par exemple
l'inventeur jacques vaucanson aurait
créé un canal artificiel
le canard digère acteur capable de nager
et de digérer comme un véritable canard
son but c'était de montrer que les
mouvements vitaux dépendent entièrement
des lois de la mécanique alors des
cartes entre voit tout de même une
objection les animaux font beaucoup de
choses mieux que les hommes par exemple
aristote entend beaucoup mieux que moi
certes mais est ce que le comportement
animal en est loin mécanique est ce
qu'une machine fait forcément moins bien
que l'homme au contraire une montre par
exemple indique bien mieux leur que moi
bon on l'a compris pour des cartes
aristote est juste une machine élaboré
mais moi qu'est-ce que je suis alors
[Musique]
à bien considérer mon corps et bien il
ne serait pas si différent que ça de
celui d'aristote
bien sûr je suis plus grands plus lourds
etc mais moi aussi j'ai un instinct
certes probablement beaucoup plus
atténué un instinct qui me fait réagir
de manière mécanique aux stimuli de mon
environnement
par exemple vous avez peut-être déjà eu
droit chez le médecin un petit coup de
marteau sur le genou en fait c'est un
examen clinique pour tester les réflexes
des tendons c'est pour ça que le marteau
s'appelle un marteau un réflexe si tout
va bien le corps doit normalement faire
un mouvement immédiat totalement
involontaire et stéréotypé comme s'il
était une machine programmée pour des
cartes le corps humain est donc aussi
comparable à une machine vu que la
matière était entièrement régie par des
causes mécaniques qu'elle ne peut être
expliquée que par la physique et
mathématiques et que mon corps ont fait
de matière eh bien il obéit entièrement
à des voix mécanique qui sont pour des
cartes les lois universelles de la
nature ce faisant des cartes des cas
difficiles la prononciation la des
cartes et cartes notamment le vitalisme
la doctrine selon laquelle il existerait
une force vitale qui serait à l'origine
du mouvement de la matière vivante et
dont les lois mécanique ne pourrait pas
rendre compte non comme tout objet le
corps humain est caractérisée sur le
plan physique par des propriétés
matérielles
nous on se focalise surtout sur la
taille et le poids mais il ya bien sûr
plein d'autres mensurations possibles et
toutes ses mensurations sont la preuve
pour des cartes que le corps est
simplement une portion détendu découpé
dans la réalité matérielle
oui mais alors ça veut dire que je ne
suis pas fondamentalement différent d'un
chihuahua
[Musique]
est-ce que l'homme serait une machine au
même titre qu'un chihuahua
non ouf descartes sauve l'honneur en
précisant que j'ai une âme tandis que
ares i stop lui n'aurait pas d'âme
désolé pourtant quand je le regarde dans
les yeux j'ai parfois l'impression qu'il
ya quelque chose quand même pour des
cartes je suis plus qu'une machine grâce
à l'union entre mon corps qui est une
substance est tendue et mon âme qui est
une substance pensante la théorie de
l'animal machine et donc dualiste
c'est-à-dire qu'elle distincts il ya
d'un côté un mon matériel dont tous les
éléments sont caractérisés par des
propriétés physiques et de l'autre un
monde spirituel ou immatériel dont les
éléments comme la pensée échappe au
chant de la physique
à ce propos je vous invite à aller voir
ma vidéo sur la conception de l'âme et
du corps de platon qui est également
dualiste soit en cliquant sur le lien
qui s'affiche en haut à droite soit sur
celui qui est dans la description
je reviens à mes moutons comme j'évite
nam
je suis capable de raisonner dans un
contexte particulier et ça ça ne
s'explique pas par les lois mécanique
la meilleure preuve de cette dimension
spirituelle de l'être humain
c'est d'après des cartes l'aptitude au
langage qui témoigne de l'activité de la
pensée il y aurait donc une frontière
nette entre l'animalité et l'humanité en
vertu de laquelle l'homme serait
supérieur à l'animal après tout le monde
n'est pas d'accord avec des cartes
loin de là pythagore qui était
végétarien pensé lui que l'homme et
l'animal sont tous de l'expression du
même principe vital c'est mieux c'est un
an
on peut aussi penser à montagne qui a
affirmé que la distance séparant
certains hommes peut être supérieure à
celle séparant l'homme de l'animal
il y a eu aussi une extension par la
maîtrise de la théorie de l'animal
machine qui est devenu l'homme machine
ce philosophe et médecin libertin
affirme même que des cartes penser
déjà comme lui en fait mais qu'il a
conservée l'hypothèse de l'âme la
substance pensante comme un gage donné
aux théologique et enfin plus récemment
le philosophe australien peter singer
qui a écrit la bible des mouvements de
protection des animaux
le livre qui s'intitule la libération
animale
ce philosophe a critiqué la théorie de
descartes en rétorquant que la
souffrance animale est un enjeu moral en
vertu duquel est bien un animal ne peut
pas être comparée à une machine je vous
invite à aller voir la vidéo que j'ai
réalisé à propos de ce livre la
libération animale
encore une fois soit en cliquant sur le
lien qui s'affiche en haut à droite soit
sur celui qui est dans la description
bref des cartes n'a pas eu le dernier
mot
ce n'est donc pas certain qu'aristote
soit un robot ou alors j'en suis
peut-être un moi aussi mais plus
élaborées quand même
[Musique]
en synthèse des cartes considère que
l'animal est une machine parce que son
comportement serait déterminé par les
web mécanique tandis que l'homme lui a
une âme une substance pensante dont la
vie ne serait pas réductible aux lois
mécanique mais la dignité d'aristote et
défendu par son vétérinaire pour le
docteur ferrari ni aristote invalides au
contraire la théorie de descartes parce
qu'il a une grande capacité d'adaptation
si vous prenez des fourmis c'est vrai
qu'elles sont très dépendantes de leur
établissement et leur état génétique
elles reproduisent un programme sans le
modifier mais un chien est un animal
social qui s'adapte à son maître et plus
globalement a souvent vu ronnement il
peut être un compagnon ou chasseur il
n'est plus ou moins agressif en fonction
de son environnement
bref aristote n'y pas du tout un
automate parce qu'ils s'adaptent de
manière permanente ce qui est la
définition de la vie si je reviens à
l'exemple du véloce que je lui présente
ses vrais qu'aristote réagi de manière
mécanique quand il devient fou mais le
docteur feraoun m'a expliqué que ce qui
se passe dans le cerveau d'aristote
n'est pas si différent de ce qui se
passe dans mon cerveau par exemple quand
je vois un peu douteux la neurochimie
est similaire le désir et le plaisir se
manifeste par des neurotransmetteurs
comme la dopamine qui existent aussi
chez le chien d'ailleurs les
psychotropes utilisé pour les chiens
sont fondamentalement les mêmes que ceux
utilisés au lézard
le deuxième point des explications du
docteur feraoun c'est que la comparaison
de l'animal à une machine est en fait
une question franco-française la théorie
de descartes a eu une influence très
longue et très profonde et c'est ce qui
explique le retard de la france dans la
prise en compte de la souffrance animale
le philosophe la mettrie dont je vous ai
parlé l'auteur de la théorie de l'homme
machine choquer ses visiteurs en donnant
de violents coups de pieds à sa chienne
enceinte qui hurlait de douleur mais
son tu es encore les chatons en les
jetant dans un sac contre un mur
jusqu'aux années 80 90 le docteur
ferroul m'a raconté que des opérations
qu'il avait apprise à l'école
vétérinaire comme coupé deux oreilles ou
la queue ont été progressivement
supprimées car jugé trop barbare et
qu'inversement les pratiques sont de
plus en plus adapté pour minimiser la
souffrance animale
grosso modo depuis une quinzaine
d'années c'est donc effectivement très
récent en france
troisième et dernier point des
explications du docteur ferrari
la théorie de l'animal machine c'est
clair aujourd'hui à la lumière des
progrès de l'intelligence artificielle
en effet si une véritable intelligence
artificielle est possible alors l'animal
et l'homme serait des machines sont pas
de simples automates des machines très
élaboré
mais si en revanche il est impossible de
créer une authentique intelligence
artificielle équivalente à
l'intelligence humaine
alors ni l'homme ni l'animal ne serait
véritablement comparables à des machines
en conclusion la distinction radicale de
l'homme et de l'animal que fait des
cartes ne semble plus pertinente
aujourd'hui car derrière la théorie de
l'animal machine se profile toujours
celle de l'homme machine et ce qui se
profile encore derrière c'est la
question de la définition de la vie même
chez wah wah chihuahua
si vous avez aimé la vidéo mettez lui un
pouce bleus et abonnez-vous à la chaîne
pour être prévenu de la sortie de la
suivante pour lire ma synthèse de la
théorie de l'animal machine de descartes
sur le site mille idées de culture
générale le lien est dans la description
n'hésitez pas non plus à laisser des
commentaires pour recevoir les dernières
idées de culture générale
synthétisée dans le format le plus clair
possible vous pouvez vous inscrire à la
newsletter
en laissant votre adresse email sur le
site
enfin je remercie le docteur feraoun
pour ses explications passionnantes qui
m'ont permis de voir tous les enjeux de
la question
je suis romain 7 aristote et vous étiez
sur milliers de culture générale
rappelez vous n'avez pas besoin de vous
prendre la tête pour vous intéresser au
meilleur de la pensée
[Musique]